the force has come under intense
scrutiny and perhaps no week more than
this week after revealing a very
intimate details of Nicola Bully's
private life that she had significant
issues with alcohol and the menopause
and there were concerns about the
disclosure of that information and how
it could be relevant to the
investigation and now as you say that
statement from Lancashire police
confirming that they are set to conduct
an internal review into their handling
of their investigation into Nicola
Bully's Disappearance in the short
statement a spokeswoman for the force
said a review of the investigation is
diarized and will be conducted by our
head of crime detective Chief
superintendent Pauline Stables she has
also pip for accredited and has attended
the national reviewer course at pip for
refers to a high level of strategic
advice uh something given by the
National College of policing it means
that someone who is well
um verse in handling complex reviews of
very high profile cases such as this one
has turned into over the past three
weeks and what a three weeks really it
has been for Nicola Bully's family still
so desperate for news anything really
that can answer any question as to what
happened to Nicola bully when she
disappeared from this small village on
Friday the 27th of January three weeks
today and we had a short statement from
Nicola Bully's father Ernie today saying
that every day is a struggle and they
just need a breakthrough a breakthrough
an answer to what happened to this
mother of two young children who are
still at home family earlier this week
saying they just want their mummy home
for a cuddle
um so many questions as I say about what
happened to Nicola on that morning this
morning Sky News retraced the steps that
what is known at the the path that the
mother took after leaving her daughters
dropping them off to the primary school
which is just a short way down the road
from where I'm standing now and of
course in course of that walk they met a
dog walker called Ron who was there the
morning that Nicola bully took that same
walk and he found or saw her phone on
the bench where it was less still
connected to that conference call here's
what he's told my colleague into man
Rashid
I thought somebody had gone to the
toilet in the uh you know that would
have been that was my first I got about
this red brick building here and I uh
well this this is not right and uh but
then there was a conversation but my
wife was trying to ring me I was trying
to ring her Penny had rung my wife yeah
um to say that she should fasten the dog
up that was that was and Penny was the
lady who actually spotted Willow
initially and saw the phone but didn't
know what was going on with the first
right yeah yeah yeah and and then after
that you know
what happened well the next time that it
was just a progression of of things
happening you know we found out a couple
of the wallpaper on the phone we found
out who the couple were then the school
was contacted and Paul arrived yeah
and I think you get a sense from hearing
that description of of Ron of what he
was doing who he spoke to you get a
sense of this is a small place it's the
sort of place where everyone knows
everyone even if they don't know their
name they know their face they know
their dog and and that is what this
small place is dealing with someone very
familiar to this community who's been
missing now for more than three weeks
and trying to support Nicola Bully's
family her sister Louise Cunningham
posting this very moving message on
social media today saying three weeks a
day without you home we all miss you so
much it is time to come home